A.
>>> HAPPY NFL SUNDAY.
WELCOME TO THE BLEACHER REPORT
BROUGHT TO YOU BY DRAFT KINGS.
I'M CONNER ROGERS ALONGSIDE THE
MAN, THE MYTH, THE LAS VEGAS
LEGEND.
I'M A FAN OF THAT JACKET.
GREG, WHAT IS GOOD?
HOW ARE WE FEELING MY MAN?
>> FEELING GOOD, FEELING
GENEROUS.
FEELING SO GENEROUS, I WANT TO
GIVE OUT A HOODIE, MAN.
I WANT TO GIVE OUT A HOODIE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CONNER, I'M
IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
TAKES, LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I SEE MAXWELL IN THE COMMENTS
SAY
SAYING DARRON WALLER.
I SEE BRITTANY BABY SAYING
DARRON WALLER.
OBJ IS GOING OVER 14 YARDS.
EVERYONE THAT I MENTIONED,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE AND WELCOME TO "THE SQUAD
RIDE".
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE CLOSER WET GET TO CHRISTMAS
THE MORE GENEROUS YOU'RE
GETTING.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL, EVERY WEEK
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TOUCHDOWN
SCORERS.
WHO IS GETTING IN THE END ZONE?
LOCKS.
WE ASK YOU ON THE APP AND
SOCIAL.
THESE ARE THE TOP PICKS OF THIS
WEEK.
NAJI HARRIS AT THE TOP.
NO BIG BEN THIS WEEK.
THEY RELY ON NAJI HAS A
WORKHORSE EVERY WEEK.
IT WILL ONLY BE MAGNIFIED THIS
WEEK AGAINST THE LINES.
J.T. IS AN ABSOLUTE BEAST IN
OCTOBER AND NOVEMBER.
JAMES CONNER, AARON JONES, MIKE
EVANS, THAT BUCS OFFENSE IS
BANGED UP.
A LOT OF PRESSURE AND TALK FROM
EVANS.
STEFON DIGGS LOOKING TO GET
RIGHT AGAINST THE JETS.
JERRY JUDY GREAT TO SEE HIM BACK
ON THE FIELD AND FEATURED.
TO GET THINGS STARTED, LOOK AT
THE FAVORITE LOCK LEGEND VIDEOS
FROM LAST WEEK THAT WE DIDN'T
GET TO SHOW YOU.
>> GOT SIX OPTIONS.
I'LL ROLL ONE DI.
>> I'M BETTING ON TRAYVEVON DIG
>> LOCK UP YOUR BOY JA'MARR
CHASE ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
♪
>> DIGS CAN SAY, THAT'S FOR ME.
>> THE ENERGY FROM THE BETTERS
IS GOOD RIGHT NOW, GREG PLA.
IT'S REAL GOOD.
YOUR ENERGY IS GOOD, WHAT ARE
YOU GIVING AWAY TO THE PEOPLE?
>> NOT ONLY HOODIES BUT TWO, NOT
ONE, BUT TWO NFL JERSEYS TODAY.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LOCK
LEGEND AND ONE GOES TO A LUCKY
COM
CO
COMMENTS LIKE YOURSELF.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
DO WHAT YOU DO.
I NEED GIBBS, I NEED EMOJIS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
>> FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO SHOW
YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
THE WINNER TAKES ALL.
THEY TAKE HOME THE JERSEY.
THEY TAKE HOME THE TITLE OF
"SQUAD RIDE" LEADER AND FOR US,
FOR GREG, GOT TO RAISE THOSE
ODDS A LITTLE BIT AND MAYBE GET
PLUS MONEY ACTION.
TRAIL THEM, GET RICH.
HAVE FUN.
LET'S NOT WASTE ANY TIME.
LET'S GET THE SHOW ON THE ROAD.
THE FIRST PITCH COMES FROM
COOZYK 33.
WHAT IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY?
>> COME ON, COME ON, COME ON.
IT'S FAST.
>> I HAVE THREE NFL RUNNING
BACKS THAT I NEED TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN THIS WEEKEND.
SEE THE CODE, RIGHT?
I NEED YOU TO PICK ONE.
>> I'LL TAKE THE GREEN.
>> YOU PICKED AARON JONES.
THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
>> DIDN'T SEEM LIKE HE WANTED
MUCH TO DO WITH THAT BUT HE
STILL MADE HIS CHOICE IN AARON
JONES, SO IF YOU'VE SEEN THESE
PICTURES ROLLING IN OF LAMBO
FIELD TODAY, IT WILL BE A SNOW
GAME.
IT WILL BE A LOT OF WORK ON THE
GROUND AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF FUN.
I'M EXCITED.
ALL RIGHT.
SO AARON JONES ON THE BOARD.
MINUS 115.
WE CAN GET THAT TO PLUS MONEY.
DECISION OF THE DAYTIME.
FIRST CHALLENGER FAMILIAR FACE
IN W TRAMMEL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> LEGEND.
>> BE OUR NATION.
WE'RE HERE WITH A COUPLE ANY
TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
>> STEFON DIGGS.
LOCK IT IN.
THE BALL IS OPEN.
>> W TRAMMEL BRINGING ON STEFON
DIGGS.
WE GOT TWO MINUS MONEY.
I LIKE BOTH OPTIONS.
EXCITING.
GREG, HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
WE GOT THE WATER BOTTLE LEGEND,
WE GOT THE MINI GOLF LEGEND.
WHICH WAY YOU FEELING?
>> CONNER, LET ME HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS.
LET ME ACTUALLY TALK TO THE
PEOPLE.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET US
KNOW.
LET ME KNOW.
LET CONNER KNOW.
SHOULD WE RIDE WITH THE WATER
BOTTLE LEGEND OR SHOULD WE RIDE
WITH THE MINI GOLF LEGEND
CONNER, LET'S DIG INTO IT.
AARON JONES, WE KNOW AARON
ROGERS MISSED LAST WEEK SO I
THINK THAT THEY'RE SLOWLY BUT
SURELY GOING TO GET HIM INVOLVED
INTO THE OFFENSE THIS WEEK.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, CONNER?
THAT SIMPLY MEANS THEY WILL RUN
THE BALL.
SO THEREFORE, I COULD SEE AARON
JONES GETTING IN THE END ZONE
TODAY.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID, THE
BUFFALO BILLS LAID AN EGG LAST
WEEK IN JACKSONVILLE, SO YOU
KNOW THEY'RE COMING BACK WITH
THE VENGEANCE AND MY GUY STEFON
DIGGS IS JOSH ALLEN'S FAVORITE
TARGET.
I LIKE THAT, TOO.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE, CONNER.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE BOOST THE ODDS UP BUT CONNER,
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
>> I LIKE THE MINI GOLF VIDEO A
LOT.
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO
DECIDE BUT I LIKE THE AARON
JONES PICK BETTER AND A LOT OF
THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE TIMING.
AS SOON AS YOU AND I SAD DOWN TO
DO THE SHOW TODAY, WE SAW THE
SNOW FIELD GETTING READY TO GO
AND LOOKED AT EACH OTHER AND
SAID AARON JONES MIGHT HAVE A
BIG DAY ABOUT SEATTLE.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT AARON JONES.
ARE THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS
FEELING THE SAME WAY OR LEANING
STEPHFON DIGGS AGAINST THE
SECONDARY?
>> LET ME SEE, CONNER.
I GOT -- THE HANDY DANDY iPHONE
IS HERE.
I GOT POPPY JESSIE SAN DIGS.
SHOUTOUT.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT TRAP TREY SAYING AARON
JONES SHOUTOUT TO YOU TRAP TREY,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE I WANT TO WIN.
I WANT TO WIN SAYS FIRE, FIRE,
FIRE EMOJI JONES.
SHUTOUT TO YOU.
I WANT TO WIN.
I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE IN ME, CONNER.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
D CAFE 7 SAYS YES, AARON JONES
SO SHUTOUT TO YOU CAFE 7 AND
EVERYONE I MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I THINK IT'S APPARENT, BROTHER.
I THINK IT IS A APPARENT.
WE'RE RIDING WITH THE WATER
BOTTLE LEGEND IN AARON JONES
MOVING ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> YEAH, COOZIEK MOVING ON.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
SEEMS LIKE THE AUDIENCE LIKED
THAT FOR ROUND TWO BUT IT'S
REDEMPTION TIME.
IT'S THE REDEMPTION TOUR.
WE GOT A REVENGE GAME BECAUSE
THE FETCH LEGEND ATLAS IS BACK.
THIS PITCH IS FROM GOLDBERG.
MAN, I THINK HE'S GOING TO NEED
TO GET REDEMPTION.
LET'S SEE IT, LET'S SEE IT.
>> WHAT'S UP, BLEEACHER REPORT?
WE'RE BACK WITH EVERYONE'S
FAVORITE BETTING DOG ATLAS AND
HE'S HERE TO REDEEM HIMSELF.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO THROW BOTH
BALLS AND SEE WHICH ONE HE COMES
BACK WITH AND THE BALL BLUE WE
HAVE HARRIS AND IN THE GREEN
BALL WE HAVE JONATHAN TAYLOR FOR
THIS WEEK'S ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE.
READY, ATLAS?
>> COMING BACK WITH THE GREEN
BALL.
>> TODAY HE PICKED GREEN BALL.
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE AGAINST
THE JAGUARS.
>> AL LAICE LOOKING TO MAKE UP
THE L.
I LIKE THE J.T. PICK A LOT.
WE NEED A LOCK HERE.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED.
GREG, CAN THE WATER BOTTLE
LEGEND KEEP THINGS MOVING OR IS
ATLAS BACK ON AS THE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER POTENTIALLY?
>> CONNER, LET'S FIND OUT BUT
BEFORE WE FIND OUT, I HAVE TO
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
YOU GUYS LET US KNOW.
ARE WE RIDING WITH AARON JUDGE
EV
-- AARON JONES OR JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
WE KNOW JONATHAN TAYLOR IS THE
ENGINE INDIANAPOLIS.
HE GOES, THEY GO.
WE TALKED ABOUT AARON JONES
PLAYING IN THE SNOW.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
I'M ACTUALLY TORN HERE.
WE'VE BEEN SEEING JONATHAN
TAYLOR BREAK LONG RUNS, BREAK
LONG CATCHES OUT OF THE
BACKFIELD ALL SEASON.
CAN HE DO IT AGAIN?
MAYBE, I THINK SO BUT I ALSO
FEEL STRONG ABOUT AARON JONES
SCORING SO YOU GUYS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW WHICH
WAY WE SHOULD LEAN.
CONNER, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> I'M GOING WITH THE GUY THAT
SCORED EVERY WEEK OF OCTOBER.
HE SCORED EVERY WEEK OF NOVEMBER
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO KEEP
THINGS MOVING.
I THINK IT'S J.T., GREG.
I LOVE WHAT JONATHAN TAYLOR IS
DOING RIGHT NOW FROM THIS COLT'S
OFFENSE.
HE OBVIOUSLY RAN WILD THE LAST
TIME WE SAW HIM ON THURSDAYS
NIGHT FOOTBALL.
I THINK CARSON WENTZ REALLY LEAN
ON THAT RUN GAME TO TAKE AWAY
FROM ANY WEDNESDAY TNTZ TURNOVE.
IF WE CAN GET J.T. TO PLUS
MONEY, I'M IN ON THAT HAPPENING.
I'LL RIDE WITH ATLAS ONE MORE
TIME.
>> HEY, CONNER, IF WE COULD GET
J.T. TO PLUS MONEY, THAT WOULD
BE LEGENDARY BUT GUESS WHAT?
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE ARE LEGENDARY HERE ON "THE
SQUAD RIDE."
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CONNER.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS LOOKING FOR
TAKES AND I SEE, I SEE NOAH
GOLDBERG IN THE COMMENTS.
SHUTOUT TO YOU.
>> HE'S WATCHING.
>> YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HE SAYS ATLAS, SHOUTOUT TO
ATLAS.
I SEE SHANNON SAYS JONATHAN
TAYLOR, HE HAS A JONATHAN TAYLOR
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO SEE BABY 170 SAYS J.T. AT
HOME SHOUTOUT TO YOU BABY 170.
PATRIOTS 73 ALSO SAYS AARON
JONES, HE SAYS AARON JONES FOR
THE VALUE BUT RIGHT BELOW HIM
RAY BOW 54 SAYS JONATHAN TAYLOR
FOR TODAY AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE RIDING WITH, JOHNER.
WE'
WE'LL CALL, IT CONNER.
IT APPEARS IT'S OVER.
WE'LL GO WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR
GOLDBERG MOVING ONTO THE NEXT
ROUND.
>> ROUND TWO IN THE BEAK OOKS.
JONATHAN TAYLOR MOVING ON.
STILL GOT ROUND THREE.
THIS IS FAR FROM OVER SO FAR.
NEXT UP, YOUNG CAULIFLOWER, WHAT
DO YOU GOT IN ROUND THREE?
CAN YOU TAKE DOWN THE FETCH
LEGE
LEGENDS?
>> HEY, CAN YOU LOCK THE DOOR
REAL QUICK?
YEAH, SURE.
PATTERSON IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN
AGAINST THE COWBOYS THIS
WEEKEND.
IT'S LOCKED.
OH, YEAH, THAT'S DEFINITELY
LOCKED.
>> THE DOOR LOCK LEGEND COMING
IN WITH A FANTASY HERO OF THIS
SEASON SO FAR IN COPATTERSON AN
HE'S GOT A JUICY MATCHUP AGAINST
DALLAS PLUS MONEY, GREG.
THIS IS A LITTLE DICEY HERE.
THIS WILL MAKE THE PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT THIS.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING IN THE FINAL
ROUND?
>> CONNER, THIS ONE IS -- THIS
ONE IS REALLY TRICKY.
THIS ONE IS DICEY.
THIS ONE IS INTERESTING.
SO THIS ONE IS SO INTERESTING IN
FACT, I DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY I
WANT TO LEAN, CONNER.
BUT WHAT I DO KNOW IS I NEED YOU
GUYS AT HOME TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW WHAT IS
GOING TO WIN THIS THING?
WHO IS GOING TO BE THE SQUAD
RIDE WINNER OF THE WEEK?
IS IT CORDELL PATTERSON OR
JONATHAN TAYLOR?
CORDELL PATTERSON HAS BEEN
HAVING A GOOD YEAR PLAYING WIDE
RECEIVER AND RUNNING BACK.
WHO THOUGHT THAT HE COULD BE THE
ENGINE IN ATLANTA?
THAT'S WHAT HE'S TURNING OUT TO
BE.
THE ENGINE IN ATLANTA BUT HE'S
FACING THAT DALLAS TEAM AND
THEIR DEFENSE IS NOT THAT
INTIMIDATING.
I KIND OF LIKE THE CORDELL
PATTERSON THING.
JONATHAN TAYLOR IS MORE SAFE
THAN YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT WE CAN
DO.
WE BOOST ODDS ALL THE TIME.
CONNER, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> MY TAKE AWAY IS BOTH GUYS GET
IN THE END ZONE THIS WEEK.
YOU LIKE CORDERREL'S MONEY BUT
CLOSER TO PLUS 100 JUMP ON THAT
ALL DAY.
I HAVE TO HAVE A DISCLAIMER.
SAME GUY FOR RECEIVING YARDS FOR
A TOUCHDOWN SO I'M A LITTLE
BIAS.
BUT I HAVE NO PROBLEM BACKING
ATLAS AGAIN.
LET'S LET THE PEOPLE DECIDE THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER FOR THIS WEEK.
>> CONNER, I'M NOT COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY iPHONE
AND I SEE 7766 SAYS PATTERSON
DEFINITELY, SHE IS ROCKING WITH
CORDELL PATTERSON.
YOUNG GRAVY 56 SAYS TAYLOR EASY
MONEY LOCK, LOCK, LOCK.
EXPERT THREE SAYS J.T. GETS A
T.D. AND BABY IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING DALLAS DEFENSE
IS CALM.
I'M PRETTY SURE THAT MEANS
THEY'RE NOT INTIMIDATING BUT I
GOT ONE MORE IN DAVIS 917 SAYS
GOT TO BE TAYLOR.
HE IS TOO DANGEROUS.
CONNER, I THINK I WANT TO CALL
IT.
>> I THINK IT'S TIME.
>> JUST CALL IT.
YEAH.
WE SHOULD JUST CALL IT RIGHT
THERE.
THE WINNER OF THIS WEEK'S "SQUAD
RIDE" IS IN GOLDBERG IN JONATHAN
TAYLOR, YEAH, THAT'S WHO WE'RE
ROCKING WITH.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC TO
SHOW YOU GUYS WHAT WE CAN DO ON
"THE SQUAD RIDE."
YOU SEE JONATHAN TAYLOR SITTING
AT MINUS 175.
WATCH THIS MAGIC.
THERE IT GOES.
>> PLUS MONEY.
>> NOW PLUS 100.
IT IS NOW PLUS 100, CONNER.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS CHECK OUT THE
BR BETTING SOCIALS FOR A LINK
FOR THE ODDS.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS AND VIDEOS AND
CELEBRATIONS, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
WE WANT WINNERS AND WINNERS
ONLY.
PUT THAT IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
FILL THE COMMENTS UP.
CONNER, LET'S GET AT THE
COMMUNITY CONTEST, MAN.
>> MAN, THAT'S A GOOD ONE FOR US
TO GET BACK ON TRACK, PLUS MONEY
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT OUR
"SQUAD RIDE" LEADER THIS WEEK
ATLAS REVENGE TOUR.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE DEAL IS.
YOU HEARD GREG SAY COMMUNITY
CONTEST TIME.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A MID SEASON
SUPER BOWL RACE RIGHT NOW AND
WHAT WE ASKED YOU IN THE BR
BETTING COMMUNITY WAS IF YOU HAD
TO PLACE $11
$100 FOR SOMEONE TN
THE SUPER BOWL THIS SEASON, YOU
GOT A GOOD FEEL, HERE ARE THE
CURRENT ODDS LEADERS NOW.
SOME OF THE TOP DOGS HERE.
TAMPA BAY OF COURSE WITH TOM
BRADY, NO SURPRISE, BUFFALO,
IT'S BEEN A ROLLER COAST ER BUT
THEY HAD BRIGHT, BRIGHT MOMENTS,
THE RAMS WITH ODELL BECKHAM AND
ARIZONA AND TENNESSEE HAS BEEN
HOT.
DALLAS WITH DAK BACK ALWAYS IN
THE PICTURE AND KANSAS CITY WITH
MAHOMES.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY CAN DO BUT
THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE THEMSELVES
THIS YEAR.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID.
>> WHERE IS GREEN BAY?
>> NO GREEN BAY ON THIS BOARD,
AS WELL.
THE BROWNS AND IT'S WIDE OPEN
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S COMPLETELY WIDE OPEN.
IF BUFFALO DIDN'T LOSE TO
JACKSONVILLE LAST WEEK YOU'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT THEM BEING
THE LEADER.
WE HAVE TWO OF OUR FAVORITE
COMMENTS.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT'S UP.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS WHICH OF
THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE?
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE TO
WHOMEVER YOU CHOOSE SO LOOK TO
THE FIRST COMMENT FROM ITS HARD
WICK.
IT'S HARD WICK SAYS TITANS GOING
ALL THE WAY AND STILL NOT
GETTING ANY RESPECT.
FREE MONEY.
>> FREE MONEY.
>> ALWAYS LOADED UP KING HENRY
COMING BACK IN JANUARY AND HE
THROWING EVERYBODY OUT THE CURB.
CONNER, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
THIS?
>> IT'S A LITTLE RICH.
I THINK DERRICK HENRY WILL BE
BACK.
HE'S GOING TO REHAB LIKE AN
ABSOLUTE MONSTER AND HE'S
DIFFERENT.
IT COMES DOWN TO ONE THING FOR
ME HERE, GREG, BESIDES THE FACT
THEY LOST TO THE NEW YORK JETS,
WHICH GIVES ME THE ULTIMATE
FEAR.
YOU CAN PICTURE TANNEHILL WITH
THAT?
I LIKE THE BOLDNESS.
I LIKE HOW HOLT TT THEY HAVE BE
FOR WEEKS NOW.
I'M NOT THERE YET MY MAN.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S FREE
MONEY, CONNER.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S FREE
MONEY.
I LIKE THE BOLDNESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> FREE MONEY FOR THE BOOKS.
YEAH, IT'S HARD FOR ME PUTTING
MONEY ON TANNEHILL TO WIN
CHAMPIONSHIP.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
COMMENT FROM POLO 0424.
CONNER, NFC TEAM WINNING THE
SHIP, BUCS, RAMS, PACKERS THERE
IS NO TEAM IN THE AFC I HAVE
FAITH IN WINNING IT ALL.
IF THE BILLS GO ANOTHER SUPER
BOWL LOSS FOR THAT FRANCHISE,
WOW, THAT IS BOLD.
HE'S JUST WRITING OFF THE BILLS
AUTOMATICALLY BEFORE THE GAME IS
EVEN SET UP OR BEFORE WE KNOW IF
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE IT.
THIS ONE SURPRISING, CONNER.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> BOLD AND ICE COLD HERE BUT
I'M WITH IT.
I'M LOOKING AT THE NFC.
THE BUCS EVERYBODY TEAM EVER
DEEMS AS THE SAFEST PICK.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO RULE OUT
GREEN BAY.
I LIKE YOU BROUGHT THEM UP NOT
BEING ON THE BOARD THERE.
ABSOLUTELY THE PACKERS AND RAMS.
McVEIGH HAS BEEN THERE BEFORE.
HE'S STILL HUNGRY TO ACTUALLY
GET ONE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT O'DELL DOES.
THEY LOST ROBERT WOODS BUT STILL
GOING TO BE RIDING.
MAYBE THEY GET CAM ACRES BACK.
THEY'RE HOPING FOR THAT.
I LIKE THIS COMMENT A LOT.
I THINK IT WILL BE AN NFC SUPER
BOWL YEAR.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, I LIKE THE PACKERS.
I ALSO LIKE THE BILLS BUT NFC
DOES HAVE THE STRONGER DIVISION.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS READING AND
LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I SAY I SEE SIR EASY SAYS WATCH
THE CHIEFS MAKE A TURN AROUND
AND EVERYONE EAT CHIEFS KINGDOM
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, SIR.
EASY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET ME SEE.
I THINK LONNIE, LONNIE HAWKMAN
IS IN THE COMMENTS SAYING I
THINK THE RAIDERS WILL COME BACK
AND WIN THE WEST AND A SUPER
BOWL.
WOW, THAT IS REALLY, REALLY
BOLD.
I DON'T SEE THAT ONE HAPPENING
BUT YOU ARE STILL WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
CONNER, I'M GOING TO CALL THIS
ONE.
I'M GOING TO CALL THIS ONE.
I LIKE POLO 0424'S TAKE ON THE
NFC WINNING THE SHIP.
SO I'M GOING TO GIVE POLO 0424 A
HOODIE FOR BEING THE WINNER OF
THE COMMENTS CONTEST.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU POLO 0424.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
BLEACHER REPORT HOODIE.
>> BEFORE WE GET TO THE BETS.
WE GOT PROP LOCK OR DROP IT AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT ONE GAME.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE PLAYER
PROPS FROM ONE GAME FOCUSSING ON
THAT SNOWY LAMBO FIELD WITH
GREEN BAY AND SEATTLE, AARON
ROGERS IS BACK.
RUSTLE WILSON IS BACK.
AND MAN, I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS,
GREG, YOU KNOW YOU AND I LOVE
THOSE PROPS.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> DEFINITELY LOVE THOSE PROPS.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF THESE
PROPS ARE A LOCK OR IF WE NEED
TO IMMEDIATELY DROP THEM.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO
WHOEVER CAN HELP US OUT BUT WE
NEED WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S CHECK OUT THE PROPERTY,
CONNER.
STARTING IT OFF FOR US IS
RUSSELL WILSON TO THROW OVER OR
UNDER 247.5 PASSING YARDS.
THIS IS RUSS'S FIRST GAME BACK
SINCE THE FINGER INJURY AND
SURGERY ON HIS THROWING HAND.
HE MISSED THREE GAMES, CONNER,
WILL HE BE ABLE TO GET THE
SEAHAWKS' OFFENSE GOING AGAIN?
I DO NOT THINK SO.
I DON'T THICNK HE'S GOING TO HI
THIS OVER ON THE PASSING YARDS
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT IT
IS, WHAT THE WEATHER IS LIKE IN
GREEN BAY, CONNER.
WE KNOW WHAT THE WEATHER IS LIKE
IN GREEN BAY.
RUSS COMING OFF INJURY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'LL PUT MY
MONEY ON THE OVER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> HE DID THIS THE FIRST THREE
WEEKS OF THE SEASON AND WENT
OVER THIS MARKER AND HAD NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS GREG, YOU NAILED
IT, THE WEATHER ISN'T AN ISSUE.
NUMBER TWO, THIS IS OUT OF HIS
HANDS FOR THE MOST PART.
LOOK AT THE TOP QUARTERBACKS IN
THE LEAGUE WHETHER IT'S ALLEN,
MAHOMES, STAFFORD, THEY'RE
DROPPING BACK 40 PLUS TIMES A
GAME FOR THE MOST PART FOR RUSS
HE'S IN BETWEEN 23 TO 32 PASS
ATTEMPTS.
THAT'S NOT A LOT AND THIS NUMBER
WHILE IT'S NOT THAT HIGH, YOU
GOT THE CONDITIONS AGAINST YOU.
YOU GOT YOUR OWN OFFENSIVE GAME
PLAN AGAINST YOU AND YOU'RE
COMING BACK FROM INJURY SO THIS
IS A PROP I TRADITIONALLY WOULD
STAY AWAY FROM BECAUSE OF THE
UNKNOWN OF THE WEATHER, THE
INJURY BUT I LIKE THE UNDER
BECAUSE SEATTLE'S GAME PLAN IS
RUN, RUN, RUN, RUN WEEK AFTER
WEEK.
>> YES, SIR, THEY LOVE TO POUND
THE BALL IN SEATTLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COMMENTS,
EVERYONE IS RIDING WITH BOTH OF
US.
I HAVE MATT IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING SNOWING, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH THE HOODIE.
DBOY 22 SAYS RUSS GETS 50 PLUS
RUSHING YARDS.
I BELIEVE HE SAID UNDER ON THE
PASSING TOTAL BUT HE SAYS 50
PLUS RUSHING YARDS.
SHUT
SHUTOUT TO YOU D BOY 22.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME, CONNER.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
I GOT VINARI SAYS UNDER, UNDER,
UNDER, SHUT OUTT TO YOU AND
EVERYONE I MENTIONED.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LET'S MOVE ONTO THE NEXT PROP.
AARON JONES, THE GUY WE TALKED
ABOUT HIM EARLIER.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HIS RUSH YARDS,
CONNER.
WILL HE GO OVER OR UNDER 60.5?
AARON JONES HADN'T HAD A RUN FOR
MORE THAN 20 YARDS OVER THE PAST
THREE GAMES.
THE PACKERS ARE ROTATING A.J.
DILLON IN THE BACKFIELD NOW MORE
FREQUENTLY SO TAKING SNAPS AWAY.
WILL HAVING AARON RODGERS GET
JONES BACK ON TRACK?
>> I THINK IT WILL.
GO AHEAD, GREG.
>> I THINK, YES, CONNER.
I THINK YES.
I THINK IT WILL BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO GET AARON ROGERS BACK
INTO THE FLOW THE HE TOOK LAST
WEEK OFF.
SO HOW DO YOU DO THAT, CONNER?
YOU RUN THE BALL.
DO YOU RUN OFF THE RUN AND THEN
YOU OPEN UP THE OFFENSE.
SO I DO SEE AARON JONES GETTING
THE ROCK TODAY.
I'M GOING TO GO OVER 60.5.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, CONNER?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I AM, TOO.
THAT SURPRISED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE'S ONLY DONE THIS FOUR OUT OF
THE NINE GAMES AND GONE OVER THE
MARKER.
HE'S NOT SOMEBODY THAT
TRADITIONALLY RUSHES FOR
INSANELY HIGH TOTALS BUT
RECEIVING YARDS COMBINED WITH
THE RUSHING AND GETTING IN THE
END ZONE.
WHY I LIKE THE OVER, THE
CONDITIONS THEY GOT TO RUN THE
BALL.
HE SPLITS TIME WITH A.J. DILLON
BUT COMING BACK, I DON'T THINK
THIS IS A GAME HE'S DROPPING
BACK AND THROWING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND I DO THINK THIS IS
FINALLY THE WEEK AARON JONES CAN
BREAK OFF ONE OF THOSE BIG RUNS
THAT SUPPLEMENTS THE YARDAGE
TOTAL, AS WELL.
SO TRADITIONALLY, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THIS ON PAPER, IT SCREAMS
STAY AWAY.
THIS IS NOT A RELIABLE PROP BET
BUT OVERALL, BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION, I ACTUALLY LIKE THIS
ONE A LOT.
I'LL GO WITH THE OVER.
>> CONNER, IT APPEARS THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMENTS ARE RIDING WITH
US, AS WELL.
I GOT D CAFE 7 SAYS BIG NIGHT
FOR JONES, SHUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
H. SMITH 125 SAYS OVER, OVER,
OVER, SHUT JOULOUT TO YOU WALKI
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ONE MORE.
LOGAN L 3 IGGS SAYS OVER LOCK IT
AND HEY, THE PEOPLE ARE RIDING,
CONNER.
THE PEOPLE ARE RIDING WITH US.
THEY'RE RIDING WITH AARON JONES
OVER.
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYONE I SAID YOU
GUYS ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH
THE HOODIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BOLDEST BETS OF THE WEEK, THE
BEST TIME OF THE WEEK, GREG.
LET'S GET INTO IT, WE NEED THE
PEOPLE INVOLVED BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU STILL GOT ANOTHER BIG GIVE
AWAY AND WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE
MONEY SO LET'S NOT WASTE ANY
TIME.
>> YES, YES, WHAT I NEED YOU
GUYS TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND GIVE US A BOLD BET.
GIVE US A LONG SHOT.
GIVE US YOUR LONGEST LONG SHOT.
IT COULD BE A PARLAY.
ANYTHING.
WE JUST WANT LONG SHOTS IN THE
COMMENTS.
ALSO TELL ME IF YOU'RE RIDING
WITH ME OR IF YOU'RE RIDING WITH
CONNER'S BOLDEST BET BUT CONNER,
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT, MAN.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
WHAT DO YOU GOT AS YOUR BONUS
BET THIS WEEK?
>> GETTING BACK IN THE PARLAY,
GREG.
STAYING AWAY FROM TWO TOUCHDOWNS
FOR ONCE AND GETTING BACK INTO
THE PARLAY HERE.
TOUCHDOWN SCORES THREE LEG.
I LIKE THE TEAM'S THAT THESE
GUYS ARE PLAYING.
JOSH ALLEN AGAINST THE JETS.
NA J
NAJI HARRIS, JONATHAN TAYLOR OUR
SQUAD RIDE LEADER AGAINST
JACKSONVILLE.
THESE GUYS ARE RELIABLE ON THE
GROUND AND WEEK AFTER WEEK
PRETTY MUCH AND WITH THE
THREE-LEG PARLAY ON DRAFT KINGS,
GOT A LITTLE PROFIT BOOSTER
THERE.
THIS IS OVER PLUS 500.
THE THREE LEG PARLAY FOR THE
1:00 SLATE, I'M FEELING GOOD.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU GOT HERE?
>> CONNER, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE COWBOYS LAST WEEK THEY LAID
AN EGG LAST WEEK AGAINST THE
BRONCOS BUT GUESS WHAT, CONNER?
THEY'RE PLAYING AGAIN TODAY.
THEY'RE PLAYING AGAIN TODAY AND
I THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET THEIR OFFENSE GOING.
THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR OFFENSE
GOING AND HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
YOU PLAY PHYSICAL AND YOU RUN
THE BALL SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID, I GOT MY BOY ZEKE ZEKE YE
ELLI
ELLIOTT.
COACH, FEED ZEKE, FEED HIM AND
LET'S GET TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
I LIKE IT.
GET THE OFFENSE GOING, RUN THE
BALL, FEED ZEKE.
SIMPLE, LET'S GO.
>> ALL THE WIDE RECEIVERS ARE
NURSING INJURIES.
THEY GOT TO GET BACK TO WHAT
WORKS AND THE ORIGIN OF THIS.
THE OFFENSIVE LINE RUNNING,
RUNNING, RUNNING, HELP DAK OUT.
I LIKE THAT.
FEELING GOOD ABOUT IT.
GOT TO KNOW TWO THINGS, I NEED
TO KNOW WHO ARE THE PEOPLE
RIDING WITH, MY RIDICULOUS
PARLAY OR ALL IN ON ZEKE AND YOU
HAVE A JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY ON
THE COMMENT QUESTION.
>> LOOK, I SEE A BUNCH OF TAKES
IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M LOVING THE LONG SHOTS.
I GOT ISAAC BOATMAN AND SORRY,
CONNER, THIS ONE -- NO, NO, NO,
THIS IS NOT WHAT I DID.
THIS IS HE'S GOING WITH JONATHAN
TAYLOR TWO TOUCHDOWNS PLUS
INDIANAPOLIS SPREAD.
GOING WITH JONATHAN TAYLOR TWO
TOUCHDOWNS PLUS INDIANAPOLIS
SPREAD.
ISAAC THAT DESERVES A JERSEY.
THAT DESERVES A JERSEY.
LOVE THE TAKE.
>> J.T. JERSEY ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> TAKE THIS JERSEY MONEY AND GO
GET A J.T. JERSEY.
I SEE EXPERT SAYS JARED GOFF
THREE TDs, THOSE HAVE TO BE
INSANE.
>> ASTRONAUT.
>> THOSE ODDS HAVE TO BE INSANE.
COWBOY BOUNCE BACK ZEKE SCORES
TWO TOUCHDOWNS, SHUTOUT TO
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY WATCHING,
MAN.
CONNER, YOU MIGHT WANT TO START
TALKING BEFORE I START GIVING
AWAY MORE HOODIES, BROTHER.
CHRISTMAS IS COMING UP.
>> YEAH, WE GOT A LOT --
>> KEEP GOING.
KEEP GOING, KEEP GOING.
>> I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
DONTE SAYS LIONS MONEY LINE.
>> SHENZO.
MONEY LINE.
HE'S REACTING TO THE BIG BEN
NEWS.
THEY NEED A WIN.
THEY PLAY HARD FOR THE COACH.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE FUN OF IT.
I'M SCARED OF IT.
I HAVE THE SPREAD WHEN IT OPENED
BUT I'M NOT -- WE'LL SEE.
>> YEAH.
>> WE'LL SEE.
I LIKE HOW EVERYBODY IS GETTING
ON THE BOLDEST BETS TRAIN.
NOT JUST YOU AND I SITTING UP
HERE THROWING OUT PLUS 300, PLUS
500.
EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN MAYHEM.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
THIS WAS A BLAST.
I FEEL LIKE THE COMMENTS REALLY
BROUGHT IT TODAY.
CONGRATS TO THE HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
IF YOU DON'T HEAR FROM SOMEONE
RIGHT AWAY, YOU WILL.
WITHIN 24 HOURS WE'LL DM YOU AND
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
KO
COOZIE K, THE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER, YOUNG CAULIFLOWER.
DROP REALTIME TAKES IN THE
SPORTS BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM
AND BR APP AND FOLLOW US ON IG
STORIES ALL DAY ALONGSIDE THE
MAN IN THE NICE JACKET.
GREG IVORY.
I'M CONNER ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT TIME, SAME PLACE,
SAME TIME.
SEE YOU NEXT TIME.
♪